Film Courage: We talked earlier about where
there was a time where you got kind of stuck
in this place where you could not really move.
You didn’t want to do this, you did not
want to do that and you did not know it was
depression.
Can you talk about what happened?
Dui Jarrod, Writer/Director: When I started
to understand what depression was, there is
the clinical definition when you really get
down to it is you’re unable to make a decision
to move either forward or backwards.
You’re really stuck in this very specific
place.
When I first moved to New York I didn’t
realize that I had been going through such
a depression because I wasn’t able to write…a
play, an essay, anything.
I wasn’t able to do anything.
And I also wasn’t able to make a decision
about what my life was about to look like.
When I started to deal with that I definitely
decided to get with a therapist and work through
the process of where I was and where I was
eventually trying to go.
And after being able to identify a lot of
decisions that I was making in the present
was rooted in a lot of stuff that I had done
and deal with in the past, like losing my
job and trying to prove to people that I had
worthiness even though something very valuable
to me was actually taken away.
One of the things that the therapist said
that really began to transform me was 1) He
said “Nobody is responsible for your life
but you.
And how you engage and get back to you is
you do the things that you want to do.”
The things that you enjoy, the things that
make you happy.
And through that you will be able to kind
of start seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel.
That’s when I started to go to as much theater
as I could in New York.
It was like a seed that had been watered where
it was like I was dead in my creative ability
and I started to really flourish and start
coming up with ideas and started to see the
definition of who I was.
There was one specific play called Sunset
Baby written by Dominique Morisseau that I
think really defined me and my personal journey
because she was trying to just go get on a
flight and get away and that is all I was
ever trying to do was kind of get away and
escape the past instead of embracing the past
and using it as fuel to create everything
in the present.
Just kind of what I went through and how I
was able to get back on the other side.
Fortunately I have not experienced that in
a long time.
Film Courage: Sunset Baby?
Dui: Sunset Baby.
Film Courage: And you saw this in New York?
Dui: I saw it in New York at the LAByrinth
Theater.
It was unexpected but it was such a great
piece of poetic work.
It was just tremendous.
Film Courage: Did you reach out to the playwright?
Dui: No I never did.
I never reached out and it’s interesting
enough because I have met other writers who
know exactly who she is and so maybe the Universe
will align and I will one day see her and
look at her and say “This play really helped
heal the journey that I had internally.”
Film Courage: It helped heal but you also
wanted to write plays like that?
Dui: That were affecting and I understood
that what made it so affective is that it
came from a very real place inside of her
and again I wasn’t in a writing place because
I was trying to hide so much of who I was
from the rest of the world I wasn’t able
to authentically tell these really deep and
rich stories.
Once I started to be okay with me and who
I was I was able to go out and start really
telling stories in an authentic and rich way.
While it has not necessarily caught on to
the popular culture, people that have been
able to witness my work have been affected
by it and that is what I am grateful for.
Film Courage: Do you remember what it was
like leaving the theater after you watched
it?
Were you in one of these dazes?
Dui: I was!
It was hard to get to that theater too because
that theater is not by the train.
And I remember not wanting to leave the theater.
I didn’t really want to leave the theater
so I remember sitting there for just a half
second longer than what I should have and
then immediately we went across the street
and I wanted to regurgitate and just talk
about the piece and talk about the journey.
And it’s been so many amazing plays that
I have seen in New York, so many incredible
plays and playwrights that people would probably
never see their work staged but it’s an
incredible group of writers and talent to
pull from in New York.